hello welcome to this video pairing
playing Peregrine 64 let's see what we
get the Sicilian and try this out I know
it allows the maroc see which is not my
favorite kind of opening but I recently
stolen an idea that I liked so I'm going
to see to get to that this is a
transposition to the standard line look
see one is possible it's slightly
slightly in precise oh it takes yeah
this is normally not giving black any
big issues and because of the dark
squares so we would seem see what
happens
normally bit should be three is more
testing keeping the bishops on the board
okay so um i won f4 so this idea i will
probably play you five against f freue
mind we five i don't think i can take it
but if i should be fine yeah okay can I
take this on your TSA sf6 coming so I'm
just being conservative and believe I'm
here yeah it's not ideal because Niger
is 62 d for ism is an idea
so this is closed hmm ya can also still
play on the default but i am not quite
sure what he's how is some planning to
go about it yeah i wonder if i should do
that pre-empting things actually h yeah
maybe it's okay Luke h3 h4 it's a little
bit off but I totally forgot that whoo
whoo that's not good Wow no I totally
forgot that rope f2 was attacking this
check
check mm-hmm ok so this ending is of
course better for white he has a pawn
but it's something that has to be
converted
yeah I am I thinking would be five year
force but I don't know if it's really
doing that much probably not check
hmm that's not so easy to get rolling
those pawns IAM i was thinking even be
five here i takes root c3 that could be
interesting okay maybe this is too much
but it seemed I mean he's two pawns up
now but they are mostly week yeah this
son but i'm not sure about all this
threatening 95 now check I can take it
huh he's a nap in a kinky 295 smarter
not clear at all or even King King no
king before stupid his fattening Bishop
c4 here and here so 95 is the move
f6 is hanging unfortunately this is a
bit of a problem
94 it but that's you put should be ok
this one check
Jim this is not a clear situation here
not at all I'm pulling up now hmm k this
hangs just can do this you cannot get to
time morning Hans all that easily now
the night is Oh what's dead he played
King c3 I didn't oh my god I just didn't
see that wow wow as these are the yachty
games here that black reason from going
to 2500 more often just just took just a
probably winning ending for nothing I
know it was a big blackout and quite
rare I don't do that too often I was
just thinking he takes h4 I take g2 no
way he didn't he didn't he played King
c3 now I don't know this is just a
blackout just a blackout yeah I'm here
of course i blundered this pawn and was
in trouble but then he played the
endgame so badly Chad I got a winning
position again yeah this is already a
lot a good technical play because the
pawns cannot cannot move 95 is just a
clear mistake you should never do that
give me night against bishop in this
position you can very slowly here
prepare before and then you're better
check this distance of course still
better for why but you're not winning
all that easily now and here I'm already
better taking on b5 is the next problem
Chang this is now beginning ending I
know I mean I even have much more time
on the clock so it's just kind of
kind of funny that I what I did here
even if I don't find a window on the
board I would always been on time this
position and yes I just find just blunt
at this what can you do okay thanks for
watching